let's get right into that futurecast
we're going to show you really the areas
that could potentially be getting a
little bit of that moisture kicking in
for tomorrow as you can see areas north
of las vegas like caliente and ph can
definitely see a little bit of that
activity slight chances kicking in the
las vegas valley u will be extremely dry
all weekend long we do expect most of
the moisture to stick around for
northwest arizona as of right now wind
speeds remaining pretty breezy out there
you notice the blue the green that's
representing those breezes nothing
criteria level that's good news right
speeds remaining below 10 miles per hour
for some of your areas we do expect a
few gusts up to 20 miles per hour so
expect those occasional breezes back
again for tomorrow as for the alerts you
can see we are staying alert free pretty
quiet but the heat will be the primary
concern and it starts right away in the
morning hours so if you're looking to
exercise or even walk your dog it's best
to do so before 8 am or even at night
focusing on your day planner tomorrow
you notice the temperature increasing
104 around that 3pm hour it's going to
be another hot one sticking around for
that 6pm hour it will increase the
temperature even more slightly above the
average but for some of you still
sticking pretty close to there so
sunshine kicking in 106 on sunday monday
105 it's going to be fairly consistent
so tonight temperatures will drop in the
80s we'll have mostly clear skies here's
a look at your sally j 8 day forecast
where we're tracking that normal
temperature it should be 102 those lows
should be of 79 degrees and you can see
we're going to be above the average 105
106 consistent as we finish the week
reminding you back again with that light
loose clothing white is always a great
color drink plenty of water and eat that
fresh fruit like watermelon over to you
guys